[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
patience et prudent sur la route vous
serez des millions ces jours-ci à partir
ou à rentrer de vacances dans la Loire
TL7 vous donnera quelques conseils pour
rester calme en voiture et la Dépêche du
Midi elle nous fera découvrir les
nouvelles voitures de sport de la
gendarmerie qui chasseront les gros
excès de vitesse tous les thés et si
pour vous défouler vous testiez le
bourde cette pratique tout droit venue
du Moyen-Âge est en plein développement
en France le but combattre des
adversaires avec des armes et des
armures médiévales un reportage très
étonnant de la chaîne TVR à suivre dans
ce journal
Ferrari Formule 1 magnifique voiture des
voitures de rêve mises aux enchères à
Monaco la rédaction de Monaco afro nous
offrira dans quelques instants la chance
de découvrir quelques-unes des plus
belles voitures mythiques du monde
c'est un classique des vacances d'été
vous serez très nombreux à prendre la
route ces jours-ci entre ce qui rentre
de congés et ce qui partent la patience
de chacun sera mise à rude épreuve
prudence donc et faites attention si
possible à votre langage au volant selon
une récente étude publiée par les
habitants d'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes ce sont
les plus râleurs de France qui sont au
volant dans cette région là klaxon
insultent ou geste déplacé personne ou
presque ni échappe mais comment
expliquer ce changement d'ambiance dès
que l'on met le contact élément de
réponse avec c'est l'inertie il y a de
TL7 la chaîne locale de la Loire
un léger bouchon dans la circulation
parfois il n'en faut pas plus pour
déclencher l'énervement de certains
conducteurs coups de klaxon gestes
déplacés colère au volant notre
personnalité peut rapidement changer et
dans la région nous sommes les champions
de l'injure 71% des conducteurs se
laisseraient tenter un des comportements
bien repérés par les conducteurs
stéphanois des automobilistes qui crient
sur les autres personnes parce que leur
grille lancée dès le passage ou autre le
stop c'est les klaxons à outrance pour
des petites choses les erreurs ça arrive
à tout le monde à nous comme aux autres
mais ils veulent rien laisser passer
donc forcément ça crée un petit peu une
on va dire un état d'esprit un peu
compliqué quoi s'il y en a qui vont de
grosses fautes oui ça m'énerve
ma voiture en ville oui plutôt nerveux
parce que moi je viens pas de la ville
donc
plutôt tendance à m'exciter un peu plus
vite que d'habitude mais alors pourquoi
la conduite nous monte vite au nez il
pourrait y avoir plusieurs explications
le stress la peur mais aussi un certain
sentiment d'impunité au volant ça crée
une espèce de d'impunité c'est un petit
peu moi je compare ça au haters sur les
réseaux qui vont
donner des avis très négatifs alors que
s'ils étaient face à la personne ils ne
le feraient pas la voiture comme
Internet va créer une espèce de
protection d'écran protecteur qui fait
que la personne va se lâcher tout
simplement donc ça va être un exutoire
en sécurité dans l'habitacle de sa
voiture la personne la plus gentille
peut ainsi ressortir toutes ces
frustrations et son stress ce qui n'est
pas forcément une bonne chose il y a
d'autres façons de le faire parce qu'il
y a quand même les autres autour et il y
a beaucoup de valeur qui sont perdus
notamment celle du vivre ensemble mais
encore plus avec le covid et de la
politesse tout simplement quand on est
en stress et bien on va réagir avec
vraiment notre cerveau primitif et les
réactions sont beaucoup plus primitives
quand on a le temps pour penser les
choses pour faire les choses
tranquillement on peut réfléchir et
avoir d'autres réactions alors même si
ça peut faire du bien parfois il est
recommandé d'éviter ce genre de
comportement le conseil est de rester
vigilant et de privilégier le calme pour
vos déplacements
voilà pensez donc à vous relaxer sur la
route cela assurera aussi votre sécurité
la sécurité en voiture justement
parlons-en les excès de vitesse sont
l'une des causes principales des
accidents sur la route et c'est pour
traquer les plus importants d'entre eux
que la gendarmerie nationale est
désormais équipée d'une nouvelle voiture
de sport l'Alpine A110 ses performances
lui permettent notamment de chasser les
excès supérieurs à 40 km/h images et
interview recueillies par Clément Gassi
pour notre partenaire de la Dépêche du
Midi sur place
mission principale c'est tout ce qui est
excès de vitesse à partir de 40 km/h
donc aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
le marché de l'automobile a évolué donc
on se devait également d'évoluer avec
des machines plus récentes elle va nous
permettre de lutter principalement sur
les phases de départ en vacances sur les
gros excès de vitesse sur le sur le
réseau autoroutier et routier de la
Haute-Garonne
restons sur la route dans ce grand JT
des territoires pour parler maintenant
de la grande tendance de ces dernières
années les trottinettes électriques leur
usage c'est banalisé dans les villes
notamment dernière nouveauté en date la
trottinette électrique pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite facile à
utiliser et pratique le succès est déjà
au rendez-vous pour l'entreprise
francilienne qui la commercialisent
reportage dans les Yvelines de bigente
mais rien s’assisteban pour TV 78
regardez en faisant ça on a plus
l'impression qu'on est rentré on est on
est dans le même monde que les valides
en fait des trottinettes électriques
pour fauteuil roulant c'est la solution
de déplacement proposé par la société
omnip plus de 500 personnes à mobilité
réduite aux d'ores et déjà adoptées et
valider le concept Régis Harel en fait
partie pour se déplacer d'un point B par
exemple si on a trois quatre kilomètres
à faire dans en temps normal on aurait
pris mon fauteuil j'ai remonté dans la
voiture j'aurais fait un transfert là on
prend la trottinette clac on monte
dessus on attache on est parti et c'est
efficace la seule difficulté c'est de
faire en fait du deux roues de passer
par-dessus là quand même la roue arrière
de la trottinette après je vais poser la
sur le système et je vais juste reculer
comme ça et ça y est ça s'enclenche
automatiquement voilà c'est tout ce que
j'ai eu à faire à 50 ans en Yvelines et
grâce au subvention de l'agglomération
louer une trottinette revient entre 45
et 75 euros par mois le plus si la
solution est approuvée au bout de deux
ans la trottinette est cédée au
locataire pour 1 € symbolique nous à
chaque fois qu'on fait quelque chose en
gros il faut un truc spécifique qui va
coûter très cher et tout tandis que là
c'est quelque chose qui coûte pas très
cher primé au concours d'invention
Lépine 2021 les deux modèles proposés
permettent l'optimisation des trajets de
distance moyenne en autonomie avec la
selle que j'ai pris on peut contenir une
trentaine de kilomètres donc ça fait pas
mal on monte plus facilement les côtes
qu'avec une roue électrique devant parce
que la propulsion se fait par l'arrière
j'ai juste euh
s'adapter justement à toutes ces
géométries de fauteuil et tout en
quelque chose qui soit hyper rapide à
mettre au quotidien quand on veut faire
de la trottinette après deux ans de
recherche et développement la société
omnie a lancé le produit l'année
dernière il suffit de quelques tutos
explicatifs pour pouvoir commencer
l'utilisation sur le fauteuil la
trottinette l peut aussi être utilisée
par des valides en cas de question il
suffit de contacter la société via son
site internet à Thermomix aimerait
démocratiser ce mode de transport et
effacer la frontière entre personnes à
mobilité réduite et valide
comme les océans les forêts subissent
elles aussi les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique plusieurs
espèces d'arbres sont aujourd'hui
menacés par la hausse des températures
et l'apparition de nouveaux parasites
alors pour les sauvegarder des campagnes
de collecte de graines sont organisées
c'est le cas par exemple en Picardie de
l'arbre qui s'appelle l'orme lisse
Jérôme Bron journaliste away OTV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord vous emmène en
forêt de Compiègne à la découverte de
cet arbre et de ceux qui travaillent à
sa protection regardez
quand vous voyez une marque comme ça sur
l'arbre
ça ça veut dire que c'est l'hormone
lisse c'est un peu une mission sauvetage
en pleine forêt de Compiègne une mission
au secours de l'Orme lisse c'est cet
espace rare d'arbre connu de la région
et dont la population ne cesse de
diminuer pour en préserver l'essence
l'Office National des Forêts et le
Conservatoire Botanique de Bailleul
lance un plan de sauvegarde objectif
reboiser les forêts picardes l'idée
c'est que ces plans nous servent dans
nos projets de reconstitution et
d'enrichissement alors notamment sur les
parcelles qu'on peut être impactées
récemment par rapport à des
problématiques de dépérissement que l'on
a en forêt et l'idée c'est de
reconstituer des secteurs de forêt où
ces essences ne sont pas présentes pour
pouvoir aussi avoir cet aspect
préservation de l'espèce les forêts de
legs chiri ourscan et Compiègne ne
compte que quelques centaines d'hormis
et pour cause son habitat forestier et
humide disparaît alors dans les
feuillages a même le sol les élèves du
lycée agricole des rayons sont chargés
de collecter les précieuses graines que
l'arbre libère au printemps il faut
juste repérer les bonnes graines et
regarder s'il y a du duvet dessus il
faut surtout les ramasser regardez s'il
y a pas de trousse il y a bon état après
c'est un coup à prendre c'est une
identification on est dans une formation
où on apprend à le faire donc on sait
aller au détail pour pour les
identifier pas facile de reconnaître un
arbre parmi tant d'autres heureusement
leur me lisse à quelques particularités
on voit en bordure de ces samares des
petits cils blanchâtres c'est typique de
l'espèce
et ensuite sur des sujets plus
développés on a la présence de
contrefort sur la partie inférieure de
l'arbre et ça c'est vraiment une
caractéristique de de l'essence
c'est une fois trié et sécher les
milliers de graines prélevées seront
mises en culture par le lycée horticole
de Ribécourt première plantation prévue
en fin d'année
restons proche de la nature dans ce
journal avec l'offre d'un service dont
le succès ne cesse de se confirmer le
drive fermier comprenait par là la
livraison de cagettes de fruits et de
légumes
issus de la production locale dans les
Vosges un frère et une sœur ce sont
lancés dans l'aventure il y a 3 ans de 5
ans à 200 paniers livrés par semaine la
réussite de la camionnette des fermiers
c'est son nom n'est plus approuvé un
reportage d'Anaïs Gall pour vos
télévisions regardez les poireaux là ça
vient d'Alsace les œufs là c'est des
œufs plein air de base sur le rhume
voilà un échantillon des produits du
terroir qui composent les cagettes de la
camionnette des fermiers au syndicats
une société reprise il y a trois ans et
gérée depuis en famille par Hélène
Claudel et son frère Vincent elle était
fromagère lui graphiste et commercial
lorsqu'ils ont appris que cette petite
entreprise de livraison à domicile était
à vendre ils n'ont pas hésité de faire
le lien entre les producteurs les
consommateurs de faire vivre
son territoire avec une agriculture qui
est locale qui est bio quand elle est
pas bio qui est très réfléchie très
consciente et qui est hyper ancré ici
moi ça me parlait beaucoup donc j'ai
foncé et l'entreprise et même en pleine
expansion puisqu'elle livre désormais
200 paniers par semaine en moyenne
contre une cinquantaine avant sa reprise
par les frères et sœurs c'est donc une
affaire qui roule grâce à la
modernisation de l'outil notamment
désormais les clients peuvent faire
leurs courses directement sur le site
internet de la camionnette de la même
manière qu'il le ferait pour un grand
supermarché avec quelques subtilités
tout de même le site est ouvert comme un
magasin du vendredi soir au lundi à 5h
et là les gens peuvent passer la
commande le week-end exclusivement sur
internet ça vous permet de pas avoir de
stock et de fonctionner un peu à flux
tendu et d'avoir du produit très frais
c'est ça on a du produit extra frais et
on a on commande uniquement ce qui est
commandé par les clients un par un
système qui fonctionne à flux tendu et
évite donc tout gaspillage les produits
sont ensuite apportés en nombre exactes
par la vingtaine de producteurs qui
collaborent avec le drive fermier yaourt
viande légumes et parfois aussi savon ou
produit vaisselle l'éventail est large
le tout est ensuite livré à domicile un
vrai confort pour les consommateurs qui
ne trouvent pas forcément d'alternative
à proximité on a des commerces mais
c'est pas forcément l'attendu qu'on a
dans ces commerces là donc là on sait
que c'est des produits locaux ils
viennent pas de loin une livraison à
domicile possible dans la vallée de la
Moselle de Bussang à Remiremont mais
également dans la vallée de la Moselotte
ailleurs la camionnette propose
désormais des points de collecte comme
les jeudis à 18h sur le parking de la
patinoire à Épinal ou encore les
vendredis à 17h30 sur la place du marché
à Gérardmer pour un panier varié compté
en moyenne 50 euros
voilà et après un bon repas équilibré
vous ne refuserez sûrement pas un
morceau de chocolat à ce propos
connaissez-vous la tendance bine to bar
littéralement de la fève à la tablette
en français ce concept venu des
États-Unis s'installe depuis quelques
années chez nous dans le Morbihan
d'ailleurs en Bretagne une nouvelle
chocolaterie bio basée sur ce principe
vient d'ouvrir reportage de Karine
chevrolier de la rédaction de Tébéo la
chaîne du groupe Le Télégramme donc en
Bretagne
[Musique]
moi en Marion mes différents sucs que je
vais pouvoir ajouter etc je vais avoir
un chocolat à notre identité l'image de
du chocolatier et pour ce venu découvrir
les dessous de la chocolaterie lors d'un
atelier c'est une véritable redécouverte
du chocolat il y en a qui vont être plus
sucrés d'autres plus fruités plus amer
mais on se rend compte que quand c'est
du bon chocolat c'est toujours plus doux
et finalement on peut même manger du
chocolat noir moi qui suis pas une
grande fan de chocolat noir bah j'ai
bien apprécié la dégustation 14 tonnes
de chocolat bio vont ainsi être
travaillés chaque année dans ce nouvel
atelier des fèves qui donneront à
l'artisan une nouvelle identité mais qui
finiront toujours dans le palais des
gourmands
de la gourmandise du chocolat breton aux
spécialité Martinique dans cette édition
découvrons l'un des plats typiques de
l'île le Boyon thon cette recette à base
de tripes de poissons doit son histoire
à une ville celle du Prêcheur et à une
activité celle de la pêche une plongée
culinaire proposée par Yoann charpentier
Titi pour la rédaction de via ATV en
Martinique bien sûr
Jean Guy n’en est pas à son coup d'essai
le boyoton il est tombé dedans quand il
était petit un plat qu'il a toujours
fasciné au point d'en percer les
moindres secrets j'étais très très
observateur quand j'étais gamin et je
regardais comme il faisait et curieux
aussi s'était posé des questions parce
qu'en fait les vieux la
tradition fait le savoir s'accurer
comment c'est un observant on venait pas
comme à l'école pour dire mais bon voilà
un et eux
comme ça la maîtrise est au rendez-vous
[Musique]
attention tout de même à ne pas se
brûler
le bouilleton plat incontournable du
tricheur et comme toute bonne recette
traditionnelle elle a ses origines faut
pas oublier que quand les pêcheurs du
Sud venaient péchés pour la semaine il
fallait donner à manger à ces gens parce
qu'il y a quatre états c'était à la
voile quand il y avait pas de vent il
était obligé de montrer sur prêcheur
parce qu'il venait pêcher tout au nord
et il fallait donner à manger à ces gens
alors d'abord ça a été du le Beaulieu il
était salé et un jour trop de monde elle
a essayé cette recette le beau yeton
clin d'oeil à l'histoire Yasmine femme
de marée pêcheur est venue de
Sainte-Anne pour déguster un bon plat de
boyotons c'est une spécialité du Nord
nous on fait pas ça on connaît pas du
tout mon mari est marin pêcheur pourtant
mais on veut vraiment goûter alors on a
retenu chez un vrai pêcheur et un autre
à Mélodie tu sais au restaurant comme ça
on va pouvoir comparer un petit peu ce
que
et chaque année on va goûter à d'autres
Paris réussi pour les pré shooter leurs
recettes emblématiques attirent toujours
autant les foules
il est le 8e et le dernier en date là
encore c'est devenu il y a deux ans une
race reconnue de son espèce c'est
particularité un peu l'âge gris et des
jambes zébrés un véritable plus pour les
éleveurs de l'île de beauté qui peuvent
ainsi développer des activités autour de
la race et préserver une part de leur
histoire propose et images de la
rédaction devient télé paisé sur place
en Corse
faut savoir que l'un de Corse existe
depuis 600 ans avant notre ère à
l'époque c'était le 4x4 maintenant tout
le monde a un 4x4 pour se déplacer là ne
faisait partie intégrante de la famille
il portait les biens les personnes le
matériel au quotidien c'est la bête de
somme on l'appelle aussi le cheval du
pauvre et maintenant là c'est devenu un
animal de loisirs en général pour les
randonnées pour le plaisir pour
débroussailler les terrains mais surtout
nous en tant que professionnel on
souhaite développer je dirais les
randonnées le portage l'attraction
animale
sans transition dans ce journal du
karaté à 80 ans c'est possible un club
de la Sarthe propose des cours au
seniors trois fois par semaine un moyen
de rester en forme et de s'entraîner à
l'occasion avec des cadors de la
discipline un moyen aussi d'esquiver les
idées reçues reportage d'Enzo Maubert
pour LMTv Sarthe regardez
ne vous fiez pas à l'orage ils ont beau
avoir entre 60 et 90 ans ce sont pour
certains des karatéka expérimentés
2000 au Mans des séances sont
spécialement réservées au seniors qu'ils
soient ceinture noire ou débutant ce
cours il est fait pour toutes les
personnes qui sont rentrées dans les
arts martiaux mais pour l'essence des
arts martiaux c'est à dire
se préserver se préserver pas d'une
attaque extérieure parce qu'aujourd'hui
on va pas se faire attaquer dehors
normalement mais plutôt de la maladie et
de l'âge et là je n'a pas arrêté celui
qu'on appelle DD plus de 40 ans de
karaté à son compteur et c'est pour lui
un véritable remède c'est comme la pomme
le matin
qu'est-ce que ça fait la pomme le matin
la pomme le matin quand on dit je mange
une pomme le matin je mets moins souvent
chez le médecin et c'est pour ça que je
disais quand on fait du karaté moi
souvent je fais le médecin si le karatif
est travaillé réflexe concentration et
mouvement il permet aussi de créer du
lien et de garder le moral ça permet
justement d'éviter de s'enraciner de
s'en croquer on va dire c'est très
convivial on souhaite nos anniversaires
on est on est à la limite on petite
bande d'amis et même des fois on fait
participer nos épouses et donc c'est
génial si vous voulez ça aide aussi à
vivre à donner un mental dans la vie
c'est pas toujours facile quelques
fantôme dans des trous etc bon en 94 on
a déjà connu la maladie etc
l'hospitalisation mais ça aide à se
relever à chaque fois et c'est ça qui
est important pour moi bien plus qu'un
sport de défense fou les le tatami peut
donc éviter non pas de vieillir mais de
devenir vieux
faisons à présent un bon de plusieurs
siècles dans le passé pour découvrir ou
plutôt redécouvrir une pratique
médiévale le beourde ce sport de combat
qui se pratique avec des équipements et
des armes du Moyen-Âge une pratique
étonnante et impressionnante vous allez
le voir avec ce reportage en Bretagne
lors d'un entraînement de capucie Colin
guillauchin pour la chaîne TVR la chaîne
de Rennes regardez
c'est une pratique qui peut paraître
barbare en première vue
mais c'est en fait une discipline très
encadrée le Bournois en vieux français
et pratiquait à nous voit tout depuis
septembre un sport de combat médiéval
qui se joue en équipe et en armure
celle-ci c'est une armure mongole donc
c'est la mienne c'est un choix que j'ai
fait donc pays de l'Est particularité de
la discipline l'équipement doit être
daté et authentifié par la Fédération
Française de beaourt cette armure est
donc une reproduction du début du 15e
siècle et elle ne pèse pas moins de 32
kg c'est ce qu'on appelle un attentat du
coup c'est des lamelles d'acier
en tout cas on peut voir là une espèce
c'est comme une robe de jambon
donc on voit qu'il y a ça déjà pris des
coups pour l'endosser comptez tout de
même plusieurs dizaines de minutes et
quelques écuyers
pratique
pas pratique et sacrément lourde donc
chaque séance débute par 45 minutes de
musculation le bureau déjà c'est
extrêmement exigeant parce qu'on a une
armure qui fait 30 kg sur le dos puis vu
qu'il y a un côté lutte il y a quand
même tout mouvement et contre la
résistance de l'adversaire c'est
extrêmement
extrêmement demandeur surtout que le
casque est extrêmement proche on ne voit
quasiment rien on ne respire très très
mal donc le cardio doit être hyper
important
biceps ischio ou encore explosivité et
force le b.o est un sport complet le
principe deux équipes s'affrontent la
dernière encore debout sors victorieuse
de la joute le BO en quelques mots c'est
du chou contact en armure c'est né en
France à l'époque médiévale mais ça a
été développé en Russie et ses revenus
et une douane 12-13 ans en France depuis
la Russie là ils sont en quatre contre
quatre généralement les tournois peuvent
se faire en 55 12 21 il y a du 55 ans et
150 150 le club de Nouvoitou n'a pas
encore de quoi faire des combats à 150
sur l'ensemble des la Bretagne une
quarantaine de personnes pratiquent le
bour une grande partie vient de la
reconstitution historique mais pas que
le côté sportif aussi
l'entraide qui peut y avoir entre les
combattants qui est super sympa je
trouve que on apprend pas mal de choses
sur soi en faisant ce sport et moi ça
m'apporte beaucoup tout ce qui est
armure tout ce qui est équipement
médiéval c'est quelque chose qui est
beau
deuxième pour toi allez refaire mon ce
journal maintenant avec un peu de rêve
automobile ferrari Porsche ou encore
Mercedes une vente aux enchères pour le
moins sportive et historique a eu lieu
récemment à Monaco l'occasion de se
faire plaisir aux yeux sans ne rien
débourser avec la rédaction de Monaco
info regardez ces images spectaculaires
depuis 2010 tous les deux ans durant le
Grand Prix Historique une importante
vente aux enchères propose des véhicules
d'exception 65 voitures qui ont marqué
l'histoire automobile comme cette
Ferrari 342 1953 qui a gagné de
nombreuses courses aux États-Unis et
dont il ne reste que quatre exemplaires
au monde cette fameuse deux chevaux
Sahara double moteur construite à
seulement une centaine d'exemplaires des
voitures du groupe C comme cette Jaguar
xgr9 qui a gagné les 24 Heures de
Daytona en 1990 on a réussi à regrouper
toute une série de voitures complètement
différentes avec des voitures de course
des Formule 1 des voitures de Gran
turisent des voitures modernes on va
d'une de chevaux Citroën à une Porsche
356 qui a été retrouvée dans un dans un
vieux hangar on a aussi un certain
nombre de Ferrari importantes des
voitures iconiques du célèbre pilote de
Formule 1 nig était également proposé
lors de cette vente aux enchères
évidemment la collection de Niger Manson
pilote de Formule 1 comme vous le savez
qui nous a confié entre autres deux
grandes Formule 1 Williams qui a eu 5
victoires et une Ferrari de 89 qui a
deux victoires avec lui et c'est
exceptionnel de pouvoir approcher les
voitures comme ça qui viennent
directement de leur propriétaire mais
surtout de celui qui les a pilotés qui a
gagné avec ses voitures une grande
partie de ces voitures qui composaient
cette vente aux enchères a trouvé
preneur
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand JT des
territoires merci de votre fidélité on
se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]